una de las grandes consecuencias que
tiene esta guerra por la región del
donbass como en el resto de ucrania
tiene que ver con las consecuencias para
la agricultura hablábamos esta mañana
con uno de los directores de una de las
empresas más grandes de esta región
ellos rentan la tierra a pequeños
campesinos y tienen en su poder 30 mil
hectáreas que cultivan con trigo y con
maíz nos contaban que en este momento es
un tercio de esas tierras no van a poder
recoger la cosecha ya sea porque están
en territorios disputados o en control
de las fuerzas rusas pero nos decía que
ellos no son los únicos que trabajan
aquí hay otra compañía por ejemplo la
provincia de lugares con más de 80 mil
hectáreas que ya están en poder de las
fuerzas enemigas pero no solamente les
preocupa eso sino las reservas que
tienen de grano en los depósitos no las
han podido sacar de la región porque las
carreteras son muy malas y no tienen
gasolina y les preocupa que en un caso
en un escenario en el que las fuerzas
rusas avanzarán tomaran el control de
estas reservas que son fundamentales
para ucrania